[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend es
gibt erneut einen mutmaßlichen
Spionagefall in einer Bundesbehörde ein
Mitarbeiter des
bundeswehrbeschaffungsamtes in Koblenz
ist verhaftet worden er soll sich den
Russen als Informant angedient haben
sehr viel mehr ist über den Fall aber
noch nicht öffentlich wieder welche
Informationen erweiter gab noch warum
der Mann das sagt ob er ein putinfan ist
oder an Geld kommen wollte oder beides
der Tagesspiegel aus Berlin berichtet
ist handle sich um einen Offizier der
intern mit Sympathien für die AFD und
deren Russland Politik aufgefallen sei
derweil der Krieg für Russland weiterhin
nicht so läuft wie man sich das in
Moskau erhoffte die Ukraine tut sich bei
ihrer gegen Offensive allerdings auch
schwer dazu gleich noch ein Gespräch mit
dem sicherheits-
eine evakuierungsmission im Kriegsgebiet
den richtigen Moment abwarten um
Zivilisten in Sicherheit zu bringen
scheint unmöglich
und doch samt Haustieren bringen
Soldaten eine Frau raus aus dem
Kampfgebiet in Wuhle da
in Lettland und Polen wächst derweil die
Angst vor einer Ausweitung des Krieges
wie hier an der lettischen Grenze zu
Belarus ein Stahlzaun etwas Stacheldraht
und ein paar bewaffnete Soldaten
ungenügend sagt die Regierung in Riga
sie will deshalb hier die Grenze jetzt
noch besser sichern
ich denke auch dass wir immer noch auf
alle möglichen Provokationen vorbereitet
sein müssen besonders jetzt wo wir die
Nachrichten über die in Belarus
stationierten Wagner Söldner sehen
außerdem soll die illegale Einwanderung
unterbunden werden auch die polnische
Regierung kündigt an ihre Grenze besser
zu sichern etwa 2000 zusätzliche
Soldaten will sie dafür an die Grenze zu
Belarus stationieren moskau sieht das
als Bedrohung durch den Westen
auf der heutigen Vorstandssitzung werden
wir Fragen im Zusammenhang mit der
Schaffung der militärbezirke Leningrad
und Moskau sowie die Verstärkung der
truppengruppierung der russischen
Streitkräfte an unseren westlichen
Grenzen erörtern
der kollektive Westen führt ein
indirekten Krieg gegen Russland indem er
das Kiew war Marionettenregime in nie
dagewesener Weise unterstützt
am Morgen explodiert eine Fabrik in der
Nähe von Moskau mehr als 50 Menschen
sind verletzt weitere vermisst zuvor
hatte Moskau den Abschuss von zwei
ukrainischen Drohnen nahe der Hauptstadt
gemeldet dass es sich hier ebenfalls um
einen Drohnenangriff handelt wird von
offiziellen Stellen abgestritten heute
abend postet Präsident selenski ein
Video auf Telegramm russische
Luftangriffe sind im Süden der Stadt
saporica eingeschlagen und sollen drei
Menschen getötet haben
aus Rostock ist uns Professor Kalle
Masala von der Universität der
Bundeswehr in München zugeschaltet guten
Abend Herr Masala schönen guten Abend
wie schätzt sie denn im Moment die
militärische Lage ein soweit man das von
außen kann insgesamt es ist extrem
schwierig sie momentan von außen
einzuschätzen was man sagen kann ist
dass die Ukraine jetzt wieder zurück ist
letzten Endes auf dem Versuch so viel
russische Logistik wie möglich zu
zerstören um dann Truppen vom von der
Versorgung abzuschneiden man versucht
die Krim zu isolieren die ja ein
wichtiger sozusagen logistischer
Schwerpunkt ist für die Versorgung der
Truppen im Süden was die
Truppenbewegungen selber anbelangt so
ist gestern erfolgreich zum ersten Mal
den japper in der Nähe von überschritten
worden wir wissen allerdings nicht ob
die ein bisschen Ukraine gelungen ist
dort ein Brückenkopf zu errichten es
gibt Kämpfe bei bachmut die russischen
Truppen vor allen Dingen im im Osten ähm
gehen zu Gegenangriffen über teilweise
auch erfolgreich verdrängen die Ukraine
zurück also es ist letzten Endes ein
sehr verworrendes Bild aber ich glaube
sozusagen die große Strategie der
Ukraine momentan ist es wieder sich
verstärkt auf nachschubbewege und
Logistik der russischen Armee zu
konzentrieren um die Truppen von
Nachschub und Logistik abzuschneiden und
dann möglicherweise eine Möglichkeit
eine Chance zu haben für entscheidendere
Angriffe aber so schnelle Vorstöße und
Geländegewinne wie wir sie im letzten
Herbst noch gesehen haben von Seiten der
Ukraine die gibt es im Moment ja nicht
nein das war auch von vornherein
unrealistisch das anzunehmen weil die
Russische Föderation hatte vier fünf
Monate Zeit ihre Verteidigungsstellungen
wirklich intensivst auszubauen also
jeder der geglaubt hat dass es so
aussehen würde wie im September des
letzten Jahres der lag von vornherein
falsch und ich glaube man sollte auch
nicht zu sehr auf die Frage von
Territorium gegenwärtig schauen sondern
das zentrale ist ich schaffen es die
Ukraine die russischen Truppen sozusagen
in die Länge zu ziehen dadurch
Schwachstellen zu erzeugen schaffen sie
es die Logistik zu zerstören um dann
möglicherweise entscheidende Angriffe
durchzuführen hier ist momentan eher
Geduld angesagt als dieses beständige
schauen wer hat wie viel 100 Meter
gerade gestern eingenommen du Ukrainer
sagen auch während ihr doch darüber
debattiert habt ob er uns Panzer schickt
oder nicht haben dann die Russen halt
großes Gelände vermiet nun gibt es ja
wieder eine Debatte also die Ukraine
hätte sehr gerne mehr von den
Marschflugkörpern die von Großbritannien
und Frankreich auch schon geliefert
wurden in Deutschland hat ein ähnliches
System Taurus aber da ist die
Bundesregierung bisher sehr zögerlich
was ist da der Hintergrund
ich glaube der Hintergrund ist der
gleiche den wir letztes Jahr hatten bei
der Frage der Panzerlieferungen die
Bundesregierung ist deshalb zögerlich
weil die Amerikaner ihrerseits diese
Kurzstrecken Raketen mit längerer
Reichweite also die sogenannten Attacke
Mass bislang noch nicht liefern und ich
glaube wenn der Knoten in den USA
platzen sollte dann wird auch die
Bundesregierung Taurus liefern es war ja
interessant das Boris Pistorius in
diesem zitierten Interview von vor zwei
Tagen gesagt hat die Zeit für die
Entscheidung sei noch nicht reif das
heißt die Bundesregierung hält sich
diese Frage offen und das kann
eigentlich nur daran liegen dass sie wie
bei der panzerfrage sich hier eng mit
den USA koordiniert und wenn die USA
sich entscheiden sollten attack MS zu
liefern dann gehe ich davon aus dass die
Bundesregierung sich auch für die
Lieferung von Taurus entscheiden wird
ein Argumentation von von Kritikern
angeführt warum man das nicht tun sollte
ist dass die eben über mehrere hundert
Kilometer reichen und damit ja auch
russische Territorium für die Ukraine
erreichbar wäre
theoretisch ist das Argument richtig
praktisch glaube ich ist es irrelevant
aus dem einfachen Grunde weil mit der
Storm Shadow mit der Skype also der
französischen den französischen
Marschflugkörper verfügt die Ukraine
bereits über Systeme mit denen sie
russische Territorium erreichen kann sie
tut es nicht weil sie den beiden
Regierungen die geliefert haben
versprochen hat dies nicht zu tun und
das gleiche würde sie auch der
Bundesregierung versprechen und
gleichzeitig weiß die Ukraine in dem
Moment in dem sie Taurus einsetzt um z.B
russische Territorium anzugreifen würde
die komplette westliche Unterstützung
wie ein Kartenhaus in sich
zusammenfallen weil die Ukraine sich an
eine Vereinbarung dann nicht hält also
warum sollte KEF dieses Risiko eingehen
bedeutet aber auch dass die Russen quasi
aus ja sicherer Entfernung vom eigenen
Territorium aus Raketen und alles andere
mögliche andere schicken und das dort
ihre Stellungen aber eigentlich sicher
sind weil die Ukraine darf ja nicht und
kann auch nicht das ist in der Tat das
entscheidende Problem also dadurch dass
die ich sag jetzt mal die die Ukraine
unterstützen den Staaten alle Angst
davor haben dass ihre Waffen bei
Angriffen auf auf russisches Territorium
eingesetzt werden gibt man natürlich der
Russischen Föderation einen Vorteil wenn
man jetzt das Kriegsvölkerrecht sich
anschaut dann ist es völlig legitim zum
Beispiel russische Bomber die im
russischen Luftraum sind und von dort
Marschflugkörper in die Ukraine
abschießen auch im russischen Luftraum
zu zerstören aber das ist sozusagen die
Horrorvorstellung der westlichen
Regierungen weil man dann die berühmte
Eskalation befürchtet die bis heute
nicht eingetreten ist aber die halt
sozusagen wie ein damoklestschwert über
den den Entscheidungen der meisten
westlichen Regierungen schwebt danke für
das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
was den Ukrainern gelungen ist sich von
Russland abzusetzen und eine echte
Demokratie einzuführen wofür sie hart
gekämpft haben wofür sie auch jetzt
wieder kämpfen und sterben das ist den
Belarussen nicht gelungen die
Freiheitsbewegung war auch in Belarus
stark aber sie ist in sich
zusammengefallen gewaltsam
niedergeschlagen von Diktator
Lukaschenko mit freundlich Unterstützung
aus Moskau heute vor drei Jahren gab es
die Präsidentschaftswahlen und als klar
war wie schamlos Lukaschenko die
Ergebnisse fälschte gingen die Menschen
auf die Straße in Massen praktisch alle
die bei diesen Protesten eine führende
Rolle hatten sind nun im Exil oder
sitzen im Gefängnis ihre Angehörigen
wissen oft nicht mal mehr wo Sie sich
befinden und ob sie überhaupt noch am
Leben sind Christiane Hoffmann Bericht
wie schwer sie an der Ungewissheit trägt
versucht Natalia pinschuk sich nicht
anmerken zu lassen die Ungewissheit wie
es ihrem Mann dem
Friedensnobelpreisträger alles bieratzki
im straflage geht denn sie hat keinen
Kontakt zu ihm darf ihn weder anrufen
noch besuchen selbst aus Belarus
geflohen lebt sie jetzt das Flüchtling
ins Skandinavien
Stimmung
ich weiß nicht was sie mit ihm machen
weil ich im Moment keine Briefe bekomme
ich sorge mich um seine Gesundheit denn
unter diesen Bedingungen unter denen er
und andere Gefangene inhaftiert sind
verschlimmert sich deren Gesundheit von
Tag zu Tag
seit alles wirlotzki in Lagerhaft ist
ist sie seine Stimme geworden der latzki
eine der bekanntesten wie eine
russischen Menschenrechtler war im März
in einem inszenierten Prozess zu 10
Jahren straflage verurteilt worden für
ihn und andere führende politische
Gefangene wurden die Bedingungen
verschärft und ähneln stallinistischen
Methoden mit Kontaktsperre Folter und
Einzelhaft
wissen dass sie oft in eine
Isolationszelle kommen es ist ein
kleiner betonraum wo die gefangen
ziemlich lange bleiben müssen Sie keine
warme Kleidung bekommen und wo es sehr
kalt ist
die harte lagehaft macht sie krank
einige werden auch angegriffen
Präsidentschaftskandidat Victor
barbarica der in Haft schwer verletzt
wurde oder Maria colias nikova eine der
anführerinnen der Proteste zu 11 Jahren
Haft verurteilt musste vor einem halben
Jahr plötzlich operiert werden seitdem
es nichts über sie bekannt und Anfang
Juli ist der Künstler alles Puschkin in
der Haft verstorben er hatte Diktator
Lukaschenko schon vor Jahren per Gemälde
in die Hölle gewünscht der vierte
Todesfall unter politischen Gefangenen
in den letzten zwei Jahren seit der
brutal Niederschlagung der Proteste und
mit Beginn von Russland Ukraine Krieg
geht das Putin treue-regime weiter so
hart gegen die Menschen vor die vor drei
Jahren sagt Svetlana ziranowska ja die
eigentliche Gewinnerin der
Präsidentschaftswahl sie organisiert
jetzt dem Exil den Widerstand
die Menschen in Belarus sehen dass
Lukaschenko bereit ist unsere Nation
unsere Identität und unser Territorium
Russland zu opfern um an der zu bleiben
er lässt Nuklearwaffen stationieren er
lässt die wagnersöldner ins Land das
bedeutet immer weniger Unabhängigkeit
für Belarus sie fordert mehr Druck des
Westens auf das Regime und Natalia
pinschuk fürchte dass der Westen
bierlarus mit Russland gleichsetzt und
die Menschen vergisst doch die wollten
die Demokratie und Freiheit für die ihr
Mann in Haft sitzt
ich habe Angst vor schlechten
Nachrichten dass ihm etwas passiert und
ich fürchte dass diese Situation sehr
lange anhalten wird
doch insgeheim hoffe Sie dass sich die
Dinge ändern und alles wir latzki und
die anderen eines Tages frei kommen
noch ein anderes Ereignis sie hat sich
in diesen Tagen zum zweiten Mal der
chaotische Abzug der westlichen Truppen
aus Kabul und die Machtübernahme der
Taliban auch in Afghanistan gab es
Menschen die Hoffnung hatten auf
Freiheit auf eine Entwicklung des Landes
hinzu mehr Mitbestimmung und
Selbstbestimmung damit ist das vorbei
und die Taliban machen auch keine
Anstalten sich vom Ausland unter Druck
setzen zu lassen und irgendwie gemäßigt
dazu agieren als bei ihrer früheren
Herrschaft
verhilfsorganisationen stellt sich die
Frage ob sie in dem Land überhaupt noch
bleiben ein die leer machen Katrin
Eugendorf war für uns in Afghanistan und
schildert ihre Eindrücke
früher hätte es hier Marschmusik gegeben
aber seit die Taliban herrschen ist
keine Musik mehr erlaubt
und so schreitet der stellvertretende
Innenminister die Ehrenformation ganz
tonlos ab
ansonsten aber so sind sie bemüht mir zu
zeigen hat sich nicht viel geändert an
der Polizeiakademie in Kabul
Polizeiarbeit bleibt immer gleich nur
jene Aspekte unserer Arbeit die nicht
der Scharia entsprachen wurden geändert
und mit der Scharia in Einklang gebracht
zum Beweis rückt das Team der
Kriminaltechnik an und sichert den
Fundort einer Leiche so wie es die
deutschen Ausbilder in den beigebracht
haben denn das hier das war einmal ein
Leuchtturmprojekt der deutschen
Aufbauhilfe und nun also
polizeiliche Ermittlungen im Einklang
mit der Scharia
das ist dabei potenziellen Partnern
Vorbehalte geben könnte scheinen die
Taliban nicht zu verstehen
wir wollen dass die Welt uns bei dieser
Arbeit unterstützt denn wir sind
interessiert an guten Beziehungen zu
allen Ländern nach den Maßgaben der
Scharia
Hilfe nur zu ihren Bedingungen damit
gefährden die Taliban auch die
Versorgung der Bevölkerung seit sie
keine Frauen mehr beschäftigen dürfen
überprüfen viele Hilfsorganisationen
ihre Programme dabei geht es für
Millionen ums nackte Überleben im Moment
ist auch unser lebensrettender Teil
unserer change hat einfach der
wichtigere der größere der drängende wir
haben 17 Millionen Menschen die nicht
wissen wo die nächste Mahlzeit herkommt
stundenlang warten Sie vor der
Ausgabestelle des
Welternährungsprogramms in Kabul Frauen
von den Taliban fast aller Rechte
beraubt tragen die Hauptlast der
Versorgung
das ist ein furchtbares Gedränge man
wird geschubst oder getreten wenn ich
nicht müsste dann würde ich nicht hier
anstehen früher hatten wir ein
regelmäßiges Einkommen aber das ist
jetzt alles verloren gegangen
Chaos als die nächste Gruppe vorgelassen
wird jeder hat Angst dass eine noch
ärmere Familie ihr den Bezugsschein
streitig machen könnte
zwei Jahre Taliban Herrschaft haben zwar
Sicherheit und Ruhe gebracht aber auch
Veredlung Verbote und zwang
noch scheint das gebeutelte Volk auch
diese Prüfung anzunehmen und sollte sich
das mal ändern an der Polizeiakademie
führen sie mir vor dass sie auch dafür
gerüstet sind
aber Szenen des Aufruhrs und des
Aufbegehrens erwartet wohl kaum einer im
Emirat Afghanistan
[Musik]
eine ausführliche Dokumentation von
Katrin Eigendorf und Gerd Anhalt gibt es
gleich im Anschluss ans heute journal
unter den Titel inside Afghanistan der
Mediathek finden Sie natürlich auch und
jetzt macht erstmal Heinz Wolf weiter
mit anderen Nachrichten des Tages
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
bringt auf mehr Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitssystem es brauche eine
aufholjagdtagte Lauterbach und warb beim
Besuch in einer Berliner Praxis für das
elektronische Rezept das ab dem
kommenden Jahr für Ärztinnen und Ärzte
zur Pflicht werden soll man bekomme eine
bessere Versorgung bei gleichzeitiger
Entbürokratisierung
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat Slowenien nach den verheerenden
Überschwemmungen schnelle finanzielle
Hilfe zugesagt von der Laien war heute
im Fluggebiet im Flutgebiet und sie
machte sich dort ein Bild von den
Schäden Slowenien hatte um
internationale Unterstützung
insbesondere auch von der EU gebeten
rund zwei Drittel des Landes sind von
den schweren Überschwemmungen betroffen
bei einem Brand in einer
Ferienunterkunft im Elsass sind elf
Menschen ums Leben gekommen 17 Menschen
konnten in Sicherheit gebracht werden
das Feuer war am frühen Morgen
ausgebrochen und hatte sich schnell im
Gebäude ausgebreitet die vermissten
wurden und Tod aus dem Trümmern geborgen
bei zehn der elf Opfer handelt es sich
um Erwachsene mit geistiger Behinderung
Ermittlungen soll nun klären wie es zu
dem Brand kam
nach einem weiteren Bootsunglück mit
Flüchtlingen im Mittelmeer werden
mindestens 40 Menschen vermisst das
halten die Vereinten Nationen mit vier
Überlebende haben demnach berichtet dass
Ihr Boot auf dem Weg von Tunesien
Richtung Italien kennterte die vier
wurden von einem Handelsschiff gerettet
und nach Lampedusa gebracht
beim amazonasgipfel im brasilianischen
bellem haben sich Länder aus Südamerika
Afrika Asien und der Karibik für den
stärkeren Schutz der Regenwälder
ausgesprochen in einer gemeinsamen
Erklärung hieß es man wolle eine Allianz
zur Bekämpfung der Abholzung Gründen
Umweltschutzorganisationen zeigten sich
allerdings enttäuscht es gebe weder
klare Maßnahmen noch Fristen die
Entfaltung des Amazonas zu beenden
sagten Vertreter von Greenpeace in
Brasilien
in den USA sind viele Studierende ja
hoch verschuldet wenn Sie Ihren
Uni-Abschluss machen sie mussten Kredite
aufnehmen um die hohen Studiengebühren
und ihren Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten
das in Deutschland hingegen das
Erststudium an staatlichen Hochschulen
gebührenfrei ist und es für Studentinnen
und Studenten außerdem die Möglichkeit
gibt Bafög zu beziehen gilt hierzulande
als sozial und bildungspolitische
Errungenschaft allerdings beklagen die
Studierenden dass die bafög-sätze seit
Jahren kaum angehoben wurden und nicht
mit den realen Lebensverhältnissen
entsprechen in der Hinsicht sind sie
auch von der neuen Bundesregierung
enttäuscht berichtet an seinem Stern
der Weg zum BAföG war für Melissa Lopez
ein sehr weiter vom aufwendigen
schriftlichen Antrag bis zur ersten
Zahlung vergingen etwa sechs Monate nun
bekommt die Germanistik Studentin aus
Frankfurt regelmäßig ihr Geld doch was
da kommt reicht kaum um Miete
Nebenkosten Einkaufen das Studentenleben
zu finanzieren ich krieg ungefähr 780 €
Bafög und ja ich meine ein Teil geht
halt an Miete weg und dann gibt's halt
so fixe Ausgaben wie Einkaufen pro Woche
ich habe das dann immer auf so kleine
Blöcke runtergerechnet pro Woche eben ja
und ansonsten so Sachen wie jetzt
Klamotten kaufen und sowas das fällt die
meiste Zeit weg der Alltag der immer
teurer wird trifft besonders auch
Studenten viele fordern wegen Inflation
und Krisenkosten eine Bafög Erhöhung
doch nach der sieht es so gar nicht aus
laut Haushaltsplan der Bundesregierung
soll das bafög-budget Sinken von 2,7
Milliarden Euro in diesem Jahr auf nur
noch 2 Milliarden Euro im kommenden Jahr
die Bundesministerin für Bildung hat
keine Zeit für ein Interview zu diesem
Thema eine Sprecherin teilschriftlich
mit niemand muss besorgt sein die
Leistungen die ihn zustehen nicht zu
erhalten weil 2024 mit weniger Bafög
Anträgen gerechnet wird senkt die
Ampelkoalition das BAföG Budget
studierendenwerke und viele andere sind
enttäuscht
wir sehen schon dass es ein falsches
Zeichen ist die Zahl der Bafög-Empfänger
ging seit 2012 von 30 auf 11% zurück und
im koalitionsverdacht war ja geplant
eigentlich die Bafög Mittel zu erhöhen
oder das die Studierende besser zu
fördern Lebensmittel sind teuer geworden
mieten Nebenkosten also da wird es schon
schon eng ein Drittel der Studierenden
in Deutschland gilt gar als
armutsgefährdet Studienabbrüche drohen
mit Folgen für die Gesellschaft eine
große bafög-reform ein neuer Ansatz für
die Zukunft wird gefordert es gibt
wahrscheinlich keine Patentrezept das
muss an vielen stellenschrauben gedreht
werden um insgesamt sind das Studium
wieder attraktiver zu machen wenn sie
sehen wie die großen Betriebe auch in
den Schulen um Personal und was die
Universitäten und Hochschulen betreiben
um Leute zu kriegen und wenn einer
studieren will dann dürfte es meiner
Meinung nicht am Geld scheitern das
müsste der Stadt geregeltlich
was der Staat in Zukunft anders regeln
könnte ist offen man habe eine
bafög-reform im Blick heißt es aus
Berlin viele Studenten kämpfen derweil
täglich mit wenig Geld und steigenden
Preisen und müssen versuchen zu sparen
wo es eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu
sparen gibt
die knapsenden Studierenden wird es
wenig trösten aber zumindest bei einem
Kostenfaktor bahnt sich eine Entspannung
kannten der Energiekonzern E.ON hat
neben anderen angekündigt die Preise für
Strom und Gas spürbar zu senken in den
letzten zwei Jahren waren die Preise an
den Großhandelsmärkten ja astronomisch
in die Höhe geschossen unter anderem
infolge des Ukraine Krieges in dem
Russland auch seine Gaslieferungen als
Waffe gegen den Westen einsetzt der
Höhepunkt dieser Energiekrise scheint
nun überschritten mehr dazu von Dominik
Müller Russell
es sind Briefe mit ganz ungewohnten
Nachrichten die in diesen Tagen
deutschlandweit Strom und Gaskunden
erreichen Briefe von Stadtwerken
Ökostromanbietern oder großen
Energiekonzernen die Preissenkungen
ankündigen auch der Vertriebszweig des
größten deutschen Energieanbieters e.ON
hat für seine Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher frohe Kunde parat
wir haben versprochen das gleich wenn
sich die
großhandelsmärkte beruhigen dass wir die
Preise senken wir senken für mehrere
Millionen Gas und Stromkunden zum 1.9
die Preise weitere mehrere Millionen
Kunden bekommen eine Preissenkung Anfang
des nächsten Jahres an der Leipziger
Strombörse an der die Versorger wiederum
ihren Strom beschaffen ist der
Handelspreis in der Tat wieder deutlich
gesunken nach den größten Ausreißern
letzten Sommer die Frage wie viel die
Versorger davon gewillt sind weiter zu
reichen in welchem Umfang
tatsächlich geben und die Anbieter diese
günstigen Preise die man jetzt an der
Strombörse sieht nicht immer eins zu
eins weiter an die an die Bestandskunden
das liegt einfach daran dass man eben
was auch der Anbieter länger an den
Vertrag gebunden ist und ähm auch die
die Energie in der Vergangenheit teuer
eingekauft hat und das bedeutet einfach
dass er nicht gewillt ist jetzt den
Preis so schnell zu senken und dann
lohnt sich eben der Blick auf andere
Anbieter die Neukunden anlocken möchten
die auch jetzt dann für die Neukunden
die Energie neu beschaffen und eben auch
zu dem günstigen Preisen dann die Tarife
anbieten können pendelt sich der
Strompreis langfristig noch etwas tiefer
wieder auf Normalniveau ein mehrere
Faktoren spielen da rein sagen Experten
unter anderem auch die konjunkturelle
Lage in Deutschland also ob die
Industrie viel Strom benötigt und die
Nachfrage nach oben treibt oder nicht
und vor allem auch das Tempo beim Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien sei
entscheidend
also wenn die ambitionierten Pläne der
Bundesregierung umgesetzt werden können
dann wird sich davon ausgehen dass die
Strompreise noch weiter sinken an den
Großhandelsmärkten und auch für die
Haushaltskunden aber es gibt doch nach
wie vor Risiken dass der Ausbau nur
verzögert stattfindet dann würden die
Preise wohl wieder steigen momentan sind
sie aber erstmal deutlich gesunken für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher gute
Nachrichten
wenn die Preise tatsächlich dauerhaft
wieder sinken freut das natürlich auch
die Bundesregierung dann wird auch ihre
Gas und strompreisbremse entsprechend
billiger und das könnte Geld für anderes
frei werden bedarf das ist ja genug etwa
bei der Energiewende damit geht es bei
dir jetzt weiter eins ja die
Bundesregierung hat den Klima und
transformationsfonds auf dem Weg
gebracht ein Finanzierungsinstrument für
die Energie und klimapolitischen Ziele
nachdem vom Kabinett beschlossenen
Entwurf sollen bis 2027 insgesamt fast
212 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung stehen
Förderschwerpunkt im kommenden Jahr ist
der Gebäudebereich mit fast 19
Milliarden Euro
China das ja auch für die deutsche
Wirtschaft ein wichtiger Markt ist hat
heute neue Daten zur
Konjunkturentwicklung bekannt gegeben
demnach sind die Verbraucherpreise dort
im Juli im Jahresvergleich nicht
gestiegen sondern gesunken Stefanie
Barrett was bedeutet so eine Entwicklung
ja erstmals seit Ende 2020 sind die
Preise in China auf breiter Front wieder
Gefallen damit steckt der
weltkonjunkturmotor China in der
Deflation im Juli fielen die
Verbraucherpreise um 0,3% gegenüber dem
Vorjahr die Erzeugerpreise sogar um 4,4
Prozent hält dieser Zustand länger an
dann wirkt das große Risiken für die
ohnehin schwächelnde chinesische
Wirtschaft wenn Verbraucher nämlich
damit rechnen dass die Preise weiter
sinken schieben sie Anschaffungen auf
firmenfahren ihre Produktion zurück und
entlassen Mitarbeiter oder legen
Einstellungen auf Eis allein die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit das in China
bereits auf über 20% gestiegen dazu
taumelt der gewichtige im mobiliensektor
ist türmen sich nicht nur gefährlich
hohe Schuldenberge sondern Millionen
leerstehender und halbfertiger Gebäude
weil sich immer weniger Chinesen eine
neue Wohnung leisten können auch wenn
die Bedeutung Chinas für die deutsche
Wirtschaft minimal abgenommen hat das
zeigen neueste zahlen die zweitgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der Welt bleibt einer
unserer wichtigsten Absatzmärkte die
Alarmglocken dürften hier jetzt noch mal
lauter stellen
vielen Dank
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 16 24 29 33 35 37 Superzahl 7
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
bei der Bahnrad WM in Glasgow hat Lea
Sophie Friedrich im Sprint die
Goldmedaille knapp verpasst die
achtmalige Weltmeisterin musste sich am
Abend nach zwei Läufen gegen die Britin
Emma finowcam geschlagen geben und holte
Silber ihre Teamkollegin Emma Hinze
verlor das kleine Finale gegen Elise
Andrews aus Neuseeland und verpasste
damit Bronze
das war's von uns weiter geht es gleich
wie schon angekündigt mit der
Afghanistan Doku von Katrin Eugendorf
und wir melden uns morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das Hoch Lotte vertreibt die
letzten Regenwolken hier ostwärts und
bevor das nächste Tief Arendt übernimmt
wird es bei uns erstmal sonnig und warm
der gewittrige Regen lässt schon heute
Nacht hier in Bayern nach es gibt
vielleicht noch letzte Regenschauer an
der Ostsee sonst ist es zum Teil auch
klar und dann bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken auf 15 Grad an der
Nordsee und bis sieben Grad z.B im
Sauerland und morgen erwarten uns dann
zum meist 20 bis 28 Grad und am wärmsten
wird's mal wieder am Oberrhein einzig an
den Küsten von Schleswig-Holstein
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bleibt es mit 18
Grad etwas kühler denn dort ziehen ein
paar hohe Wolkenfelder durch und dann
kann es an der Ostsee auch noch mal
leicht regnen etwas Regen gibt's
vielleicht auch noch in Niederbayern
sonst aber dominiert Sonnenschein
jedenfalls am Donnerstag und am Freitag
das Hoch Lotte allerdings wird sich dann
schon relativ schnell nach Osten
verabschieden und dann übernimmt tief
Arendt und läuft doch einige Tiefs über
Mitteleuropa das bedeutet bei uns wird
es wieder schwüger und es gibt Schauer
und Gewitter noch nicht am Freitag der
wird sehr sonnig und bringt uns
Temperaturen von 20 bis 30 Grad aber am
Wochenende gibt es dann Schauer und
Gewitter am Samstag eher im Westen am
Sonntag eher im Südosten aber dass der
August an sich ein hochsommermonat ist
will er uns wohl nächste Woche beweisen
die sich hier am Trend für Düsseldorf
sehen können bei Temperaturen von 25
Grad oder mehr und häufig Sonne guten
Abend